again when i was in
in egypt one of the things i asked the
guy i'm like hey man let me ask you a
question
how did they carve all this stuff in
here and he goes oh well we're you know
we're still kind of addressing no
i mean there's no lights
how what did they use to be if you did
you go inside the pyramids we went
inside the pyramids did you and what was
really cool about it was
because the guy started telling us about
the lack of oxygen in there
right so you couldn't you couldn't burn
fire in there then because you'd burn up
all the oxygen
and the funny thing was believe it or
not it smelled like urine right let's
say i'm like hey dude why does it smell
like peony because a lot of the workers
that are working here don't want to walk
all the way out so they pee inside
the pyramid because you're looking into
an area where most of those people don't
get to go
wow which is very cool because we were
military guys and he just thought hey we
also paid him for this
so it was very very cool but again so
you're looking at this
these 80 to 100 foot walls that are due
smooth
they go together you can't get a credit
card in between them and yet
there's no power it's not like a plug
you weren't in there you know
figuring out oh this is how i'm gonna
you know carve this out in the dark
right um and then then like i said if
you throw all the
the other things that go into it the
elongated skulls that um
some of the emperors and the priests had
within uh
the egyptian family um and they're
trying to say well they did that through
binding where they actually bound their
heads and made this go along
right he goes okay let's just say they
did that why did they do that
they're trying to emulate something and
they said if you look at these
elongated skulls they found three of
them in peru
the skulls are 40 larger
they're 25 percent heavier and they've
got no
it's called a sarcasm line that runs
down the center of every sarcasm
sarcasm line and it runs through the top
of the skull and basically when you're
when you're an infant it's a soft spot
so that your head comes together and it
forms right there's
like a t joint there bingo well every
human has that
these skulls they found do not have that
they also don't have any mitochondria
dna
which again is huge you would think that
everybody would know that
i think at least it's huge that proves
to you right there these are not human
skulls
they're called them uh uh maracas skulls
maracas maraca skulls
or maybe it's the paracas the paraka
skulls could have been like some sort of
animal maybe
well i mean now you just said that some
guys are asking if these maybe they were
bigfoots
because of the shape of the skulls oh my
god again a whole
subject heading to the whole ufo thing
well
yeah i don't know what do you think
about elon saying he has never seen or
doesn't even believe that you have he's
never seen any kind of ufo
he's never had any kind of any kind of
hint of alien beings and he's the guy
that's
[ __ ] scouring the heavens hey
i think that there's a lot of people out
there that haven't seen him
um if you're not looking for him if it's
not something you're interested in
i don't think you're going to see him
right you know now whether he's
interested in that or not
well that's a good point that's a good
point yeah i don't know
is do you think it's only oh look at
that
dude there they are [ __ ] there they are
dude look at that [ __ ] thing
dude they're 40 hit bigger and 25
percent heavier
what's that thing called go to the top
ancient peruvians gave themselves
elongated skulls as a mark of status
many heads from pre-inca societies
are teardrop shaped the result of
infants heads being bound while they are
forming wow you can see on top it does
have those cracks in it now this now
this skull does if you go through
put it in a paracas ufo skulls see if
that pulls up
paracas caracas how do you spell that
p e p-e-r-a-c-u-s maybe yeah
because those skulls are the lines
aren't in that skull
for people out there who are uh just
listening we're looking at a picture of
this whole
by the way we got a [ __ ] a new tv in
the podcast studio so
make sure you tune in to the video
version because we can see everything
now yeah it's all visual
so when you start seeing this kind of
stuff here that goes on when you start
looking at
again a lot of the egyptologists now are
starting to
turn and look at a lot of the
information now you know we talked about
the annunaki
earlier and the anunnaki and the
sumerians were the two that were working
hand in hand and when you look at the
sumerians
um they're an interesting group because
they were who are the sumerians the
sumerians are really one of the first
civilizations ever on the planet
recorded history
really um and they are um
responsible for the annunaki being here
and they worked hand in hand again to go
back and to
to gather all this gold up i one of the
things i always was interesting when i
was in south america i was
obviously doing drug interdiction then
and
all they used to talk about all the gold
they had there where did it all go
who got it all and why aren't they still
there looking for it today there was so
much gold
that was throughout south america
because no one seems to be looking for
it other than
you know when they find these new uh
locations now
yeah where they think that um uh the
maya may have lived
um they're now using these new um uh
shoot what they're called they can
actually fly over now and it takes off
the first layer of trees and lets them
see right down to the ground
what yeah they fly over this is a thing
now they can flex you fly over it
um i can't believe i can't think of the
name of it i'll give me a second here
i'll think of it
but they actually can it's like i'm
taking pictures and as they fly over it
it removes
all of the overbrush so you can now see
buildings and they can see cities and
they see
court ways and roads that they could
never see before
and they found like 42 more pyramids
south america has more pyramids believe
it or not than egypt has
right and mexico too right bingo bingo
so
they're now finding all these places and
again they all have some sort of
astrological
uh meaning there's everything is you
know facing a certain way or has a hole
where the sun shines through at certain
periods of time
yeah well that i mean back then before
electricity
you know the stars and the sun and the
moon must have had
so much more and so much more of an
impact on people well look at even today
look at look at their look at our
sagittarius and our capricorns and you
know we're still looking all into our
horoscopes yeah
yeah we still are obsessed with it you
know we are everybody's just obsessed
with it i mean
dude when you really think about it and
and you think about how this the mayans
were the only group
that were able to figure out that the
earth has a wobble
yeah that's [ __ ] wild i mean come on
man how do you figure
that out and without somebody helping
you to understand there's a wobble
nobody else picked up on it i mean and i
don't think that the mayans were that
smart
they're not obviously um rocket
scientists you know so
so was someone there with them helping
them through this uh
time fingerprints of the gods that's the
name of the book
fingerprint graham hancock that
basically told me about all this stuff
yeah so i've now used that guy's
dedicated his life to this stuff
completely yeah
completely and listen there's i'm trying
to think of there's another guy that
when he first came out with this
um people thought he was nuts what is
this guy he's a little foreign guy
thinking of his name now but he he came
and initially wrote a book
uh the gods the ladies the gods
anyway he came out and said that this
all started
at that particular point in time with
aliens with extraterrestrial beings and
that's how the life is set up that's
that's what we've always been a part of
nobody can tell us why though
i want to know why you know again are we
just a bug here that's producing carbon
dioxide for the planet
is there a bigger picture for us i mean
we're so interested in killing each
other and doing harm to each other
and again i don't know if that's part of
the bigger plan um
isn't that crazy though you know carbon
dioxide you know all the carbon dioxide
is supposed to be so bad but it's it's
really giving
life to all the trees and plants and and
the tree is all the vegetation dude the
tree is the most important
element on the planet what's up world
you just watched a clip from one of our
exclusive
patreon episodes that's right you can
get weekly pure
uncut content straight from the jungles
of columbia if you want to watch the
full episode make sure you go to
patreon.comconcretevideos
peace
i